good morning like so I'm Nick Ryder I
wrote this app calling sir barks-a-lot
and it's doing some bark detection of
pythons when we talking to you about my
dogs and so this is Cody he is a
miniature dachshund well he's more of
like tweeny like medium sized dachshund
and he barks a lot it's so I'm going to
be telling you more about him in a
little while but first up we like talked
about how he has a really good life I
mean look how comfortable he is here he
likes chewing we give him these like
sweet potatoes or yams on blankets for
some odd reason and lots of other things
this is his favorite ball and but he
doesn't like the gardener he doesn't
like fireworks other dogs people at the
door these are lots of things that set
him off and and by the way there's also
my other dog Haley and and she also has
a pretty sweet life and so despite their
comfortable lifestyle he still barks a
lot and we needn't ride come up with
ways to mitigate this and so we've
gotten these fashionable earmuffs but
they don't seem to do the trick and so I
was sort of curious like how much do
they bark when were at work we know they
bark a lot more at home but are they
causing the neighbors a lot of trouble
with their with their barking and so in
this talk I'm going to first tell you a
little bit about myself and why I would
build such a thing and then the
components of this so the audio capture
bark detection and then I made a little
facebook messenger component and then
some analysis that I did so real quick
before I jump into my about my me what
is sir barks-a-lot and so basically what
happens is one of the dogs will bark so
Cody or Callie barks and I have this old
web cam that I've set up with my
computer and it creates a spectrogram
and then tries to determine if there's a
bark and if there is it sends me a
message on Facebook and it tries to I
think count up over like every minute or
so tell me how many times that they
barked and so as you can see I get a lot
of messages
and so first a little bit about about me
and why I would know how to build such a
thing I'm a data scientist it stitch fix
I got into data science through Kaggle I
did some competitions around whale
detection and so all some of the
techniques or techniques that I use in
the in the whale competition like I said
before my dogs are Cody and Kaylee and
I'm mildly addicted to final fantasy
when I'm not working on Python or work
related things that I like to play a
Final Fantasy 14 so what do I do with
stitch fix for those of you that don't
know about stitch fix we are a fashion
and personalization company so you sign
up on the website fill out a profile
about yourself about what your size is
what you like to wear what are your
different style preferences and we have
stylists that go in and look at
recommendations that our team is
generated and pick out five items for
you and then we send it to your house
you try try it on keep what you like and
send back the rest and so I work on the
merge algorithms team specifically on
vendor data and algorithms so our
vendors say it's like Kate Spade or
theory I provide them with data that
tells them about how they're doing and
then I'm also working on how do we
characterize vendors more broadly how do
we cohort them and then eventually
provide recommendations about which
vendors we should work with I have also
worked on inventory quality so trying to
come up with measures of is our
inventory healthy I provide
recommendations to our planning team
about how many styles we should carry
and do some forecasting on unhealth but
but overall I build data products mostly
in Python right and other people at
stitch fix do a lot of really cool
things and so some of these like you see
a lot of interesting pieces that people
are working on it's like I'd like to
learn that so I try to find a reason to
to learn some of these new technologies
and so there's actually this great
algorithms tour of everything that we do
at stitch fix it goes through the
recommendations and how we do inventory
planning and where how
all this stuff it's really awesome I
highly recommend taking a look and
there's some things that aren't listed
in the in the tour there's some work
done with neural Nets this open-source
package called photograph I have a like
web app sort of helping a package called
Pixley and then there's this app this
Facebook Messenger app that people are
working on called style shuffle that
allows people to rate items in our
inventory but but generally we build a
lot of really interesting things and so
it's it's sort of inspiring and
definitely motivates me to like learn
something new and build something new so
and so why sir barks-a-lot well why not
I primarily wanted to learn tensorflow
just because the type of work that I do
day to day doesn't really have a like
need for deep learning or machine um
like super sophisticated machine
learning that can get away with a lot of
like really simple things and I wanted
to know how much my dogs barked and so
so this is the motivation okay so now
I'm going to talk about how to actually
build this thing what I actually did and
so the first step is audio capture so
the idea is that when the dogs bark I
have this old webcam and then it's
constantly listening so it's listening
for for any bark and then if it hears
something that's that's what we're we're
looking for and so I found this library
called pi audio which wraps the port
audio and I'm using a bun too at home so
it's kind of a kind of tricky to install
just because I happen to have an old
webcam that was not well supported by
anything but it's really simple you
basically you just start a stream you
give it you passed it this like config
dick and you start a stream and then you
can easily record so you just like if
you want to record a certain number of
frames you just loop over and then build
a list and then you can you can those
are all bikes and so you can turn that
into a numpy array
and so this thread like executes swiftly
like six every six six seconds and it
makes a recording so then the next step
is bark detection so I've got these
audio clips how do I decide if a dog is
actually barking and so what I do is
create these enclosed spectrograms and
I'll talk about that in next slide so a
spectrogram is a time frequency like
power plot so that the color is is power
and then the y-axis is frequency and
then the x-axis is time and so these
regions that I've circled here those are
all barks all right and so in this
particular case the one of the dogs
barks four times or something and so so
what I was hoping to do is turn this
into an image classification problem
where these are the things in the images
that I'm looking for it's also
interesting to note that making the
spectrogram can be done in matplotlib
using the EM lab module and so you know
you might wonder are all hearts the same
well Kody and Kaylee actually have very
distinct barks I didn't take advantage
of that yet but but you can see that
cody has sort of a deep bark that shows
up at lower frequencies whereas Kaylee
has a much higher pitch to her bark and
it shows up at higher frequencies okay
and so the first step are my v-0
detector is similar to what I used in
the will competition which is a template
matching and so the idea is if I cut out
a region of the image and I think this
is my template what I'm looking for is
correlation with along if I was to like
slide this template across the image a
correlation every point so if I do that
then I get a plus it looks like this
where at every time unit I get a
correlation value and basically just
draw a line at 0.75 and say anything
greater than that I'm going to call it
bark and that this actually works
reasonably well and so so that's the v-0
version and so I mostly use this for
data collection because one it was also
I would have this running determine the
max cross correlation if the cross
correlation was greater than 0.75 I
saved that file and now I'm building
this like set of data that I can go in
and and label and in most of the times
they were barks there's some few false
alarm sources and I'll talk about this
later
and but yeah for the most part there was
very few false alarms it limited the
amount of labeling that I needed to
because I was pretty confident but it
biases the training data because
everything is collected under this
assumption and it's greater than 0.75
and so and it's only with one template
and so if they're a bark that looks sort
of different or or don't pass the
threshold and I'm not collecting those
things and so what I also do is just
sort of slip it in anything less than
point seven five record for a little
while collect manageable amount of
samples and then go to go to that as
well but bars are for the most part
greater than 0.75 so this works
reasonably well and so I use this to
build a data set set so that way I could
get started with tensorflow and and
Charis Charis has a really nice API that
makes building and training a model like
super simple it's kind of crazy how
simple it is
so the idea actually like the painful
part was actually just installing
everything so I have a bun - and I have
an Nvidia graphics card I follow the
installation and that part wasn't that
bad the CUDA on my particular machine
I'm not sure if it was drivers whatever
that that was a particularly tricky I
think in the future I'll probably just
like set up a docker container or
something that's just fixed and then I
really stuck with just simple models I
traded convolutional neural net and I
followed the Charis documentation and
examples and so I really just went
through there they're examples about how
to build a binary classifier I didn't do
any real parameter tuning because my
goal was not to have the super precise
classifier but rather to have a
different way to collect samples and so
one I wanted to like still collect barks
but
to collect things that were sort of
similar to bars that I wasn't catching
before just to diversify the training
set and so those and then the lack
component of this whole thing is this
like messenger app and so this part is
actually really easy once I found a
barque I just want to send myself a
message on on Facebook to let me know
that they're barking so this is great
for when I go out of town because we
have a pet sitter that comes by and and
watches the dog for us when we're out of
town and so I get basically alerts when
the pet sitter shows up I get to see
that my dogs are barking that at 1:00 in
the morning the pet sitter doesn't get
to sleep so you know but it's a yeah
it's pretty useful so so basically like
I said I just wanted to know when
they're barking but I don't want to be
flooded with messages so I have a soft
follow to Facebook tutorial it's
actually really simple you create a page
so you have this case I created a page
for for Cody and Hayley you create an
app in the developer portal and all you
have to do is link the page that you
created with your with your app they
give you a token and then the token can
be used to hit their messenger API and
so it's not really a bot because if it's
just one way messaging right so that he
can are they send me messages on they
bark but but if I send them a message
nothing happens right so I didn't deploy
anything so there's no this is just
running on my home computer and it's
just hitting the the API yeah so there's
no like instant fees or anything like
that and like I said it's really basic I
have a function that sends me a message
it has some correlation score the number
of barks that occurred in some time
window and some and basically I've just
created a URL that has the token in it
and it just does a post with the JSON
right and so now I'm going to talk a
little bit about digging into the data
and so what have I've learned from all
this and so some fun facts I've labeled
just over two thousand six second clips
Kody's bark eight hundred forty eight
times K leaves bark five hundred
sixty-six times and so the interesting
thing is we always thought that she
would be like there's like great
apartment dogs she doesn't bark that
much when we're at home but turns out
she she does her fair share of barking
as well so carbon Cody barks anyone at
the door other dogs barking or just
complete silence so if he hears nothing
kind of mark Callie barks whenever we
come home she's super excited that
that's how she expresses her excitement
or if she has split her ball in a place
that she can't get to
she needs to notify us that that we
should get it for her home so I made
some just simple like histograms of when
they barked based on the hour of the day
in Pacific time because my time zone and
what's really interesting is they don't
really get going until about like 10:00
a.m. so they sleep in a little bit
Cody definitely barks more and it's kind
of interesting how they're sort of
shifted around like like Cody barks a
little bit later in the night and that
Kaley a little bit sort of oak early
afternoon so what I've done is you know
weekdays were we're at home are sorry
weekdays are at work weekends were at
home so I've only looked at the at the
weekdays and first thing that is we get
home around five o'clock or so and they
seem to do most of their barking when
we're at home so that's unfortunate
Cody in particular really likes to bark
at night Kaley appears to sleep into
like ten so yes she's pretty pretty
quiet but then at 10 G barks just as
much as he does and there's a little bit
of a overlap with the two of them
because if she barks he will start
barking as well so
they those they typically bark together
and then if you look just the weekend
it's kind of interesting it like if you
go back so there's this like sort of
bimodal distribution on the weekdays
it's just got one hump the the weekend
is the other hump and that's when the
gardener our neighbors gardener shows up
and so that's what barking happens I
Cuddy really hates the the gardener it's
like the leaf blower or something like
that out of it and then so like just to
get a sense of like on the average day
how does it look and like during the
daytime maybe like 1 to 2 or 2 to 3
barks per per hour but then when we get
home it's like more like 6 and he like
really ramps it up and so I didn't
wonder if it's like he's protecting us
or something it's kind of interesting
and so the last thing I'm going to show
are just some false alarms so some
things that the detector picked up
they're not Bart's butter but makes
sense when you understand how I'm doing
all of this and so remember I'm doing
this template matching and so I have the
template and the top one is AK off and
so you can see the coffee looks pretty
similar in the spectrogram space we have
a dog gate that closes and when it
closes it just seems to light up all the
frequencies and so that also and then
the amount of time that it takes also
it's pretty similar and then laughing
also can that guess this really loud low
so so these were pretty interesting but
it shows sort of these are typically
things that don't have to worry about
when the dogs are not home which is why
the detector works so so well during the
the day and then the convolutional
neural net that I trained because I
didn't really do anything fancy I just
sort of let it loose and did a simple
thing it picked up on some music which
is kind of interesting and I wonder if
it's just like sort of the time between
like the the piece again the coffee
shows out but it shows that
sort of knots are not unexpected and
then music and I wonder so this is the
same kind of thing I think it was like
bass or something and so if you remember
the one of the the pictures I showed of
Callie barking like she's had this like
pretty evenly spaced bark in time and I
wonder if it's picking up on that's the
thing so these are sort of interesting
and sort of a way I can sort of diagnose
like how to maybe improve the model and
so the future I'm going to do more data
collection work on actually trying to
turn it into a multi-class
classification is it Cody versat Kaylee
try to improve the accuracy and play
around with different parameter space
maybe create a dashboard to track their
their barking just something that like
maybe it's like a simple app that just
sends me like you know this is one of
them barking or this is a clip is it a
bar kiss or no and so that's all I have
I was the only thing I wanted to add is
it's kind of amazing now you can
basically just follow a lot of these
different like getting started tutorials
and and go from having like a bunch of
different things to like you know a
pretty decent working app so thanks all
right Thank You Nicholas I failed to
mention at the start but as with
yesterday we're taking questions tweet
it in at Pi Day to Seattle we don't have
any yet so at this point I'm going to
throw it open to the room if you have a
question for Nick feel free to Oscar now
repeat it so everyone on the stream gets
it as well does anyone have yes oh it
doesn't matter we're in the house the
dogs are barking it turns out it doesn't
matter where the it picks up just about
any hat room in the house and so they
Park allowed enough that if they're in
the back bedroom I have it by my
computer which is in the other side of
the house and it's still here it is this
something that could potentially become
like an echo app or something web maybe
one of the big companies is going to you
know acquire you
you know I thought I thought about that
I think that was I haven't played with
the echo API yet but it seems like a
different interesting way to take you
gotta have something constantly
listening in your house and ya be
pausing on useful information about what
other people are barking yeah another
question okay I don't know sexual dog
works very differently
so how do you really identify which part
full of which dogs based on Omega so it
listening if you want I can play a
sample yeah Wayne Barclays example the
question was how do you actually tell
the difference between the two dogs is a
simply based solely on the spectrogram
how different do they sound and
hopefully we can get some samples I hope
the audios yeah so I I warn you merciful
let's see you
so of course it's going to open all the
stuff waiting for bluetooth the links
going to like that is there a different
way I could
what QuickTime play it so I don't know
if you can tell could you could you say
I got in a balk that's just they're both
like sort of excited so I don't know if
you could tell but they were both
barking and one has a high so see
so Kaley has a really high push board
and so that's going to show up on the
spectrograms you had earlier as pick on
a higher pitch yeah high frequency
yeah so and then code uses Weiss at the
end so I think my wife is watching
fixer-upper or something like so that
leads nicely into the next question do
you have like have you been able to use
this to get a better obviously you
showed the histograms to hear when the
dogs are barking has it led to a better
understanding of why they bark what
causes them yeah because I labeled all
the clips you can hear other dogs
barking you can hear just like knocks at
the door like if we have a package
delivered or something like that and so
a lot of it is alert like that the dog
has heard something that he's you know
trying to alert us about I guess what
potential do you think something like
this has for training dogs either not to
bark or to bark at certain times oh I
I'm not quite sure sugar I mean we're
just exploring this if anyone is looking
for an acquisition yeah well so one
thing that I was thinking that I could
do is so we have a radio that place or
in the day to try to mitigate their
barking area to try to keep them from
hearing things that happen outside and
so I was thinking I could like test
different playlists and see see how it
effects out there barking dynamically
adjusted yeah when they stop talking
bots like switch the playlist right go
from the heavy metal into smooth jazz
and try and calm them down a bit we're
good if you haven't heard from them for
a while then you know start playing
gardiner noises yeah oh they asked yeah
any other questions from the room yes
how much audio daughter have you
collected I think it's just a couple
gigs at this point it's not that much
it's like I said it's like just over two
thousand six second clips and a single
channel so that's they're pretty small
so yes it will fit on your iPod you can
take a second listen soil anything else
from the room audio AUD IO I haven't put
Python package OBO please continue
like the news or that is not the
detection sequence the main feature that
you're using here like I'm here Detroit
music project so you can do like a
connection and a couple other features
which may help with that oh great thank
you yeah so for the people that didn't
hear that there are other packages out
there or Bo was the one that was
suggested just then this was using onset
detection essentially when the sound
starts we go there's a sound let's
analyze that from there and but there
are alternative ways of doing audio
analysis that other libraries are going
to help with that may give better
results or different results depending
on the sort of audio you're dealing with
so is there anything else from the room
or are we going to take a break that
looks like it might be it you have
anything else you want to yeah if you
want to talk to me just come find me or
if you learn about stitch fix new
removal right thank you very much
Nicholas
[Applause]